[Musique]
sur la vallée de l'Indre près d'azel
rideau une école d'un nouveau genre
s'installe il y est question de
biodiversité de récolte d'autosuffisance
et d'économie de moyens anneemie est la
créatrice du potager en carré à la
française elle nous accueille fin
novembre dans son jardin encore fourni
et
coloré moi ce qui m'a amené au potager
de manière générale c'est env de me
nourrir sainement et si possible de
vivre en autonomie totale en fait je me
suis passionné
et
obstiné jusqu'à finalement faire une
méthode de jardinage qui permet
d'optimiser l'espace et d'avoir des
vraies récoltes avec ne légumes
différents sur à peine un M Carr et demi
sa méthode Anne-Marie l'a inventé dans
les années 2000 après plusieurs années
d'expérimentation
elle sait aujourd'hui faire cohabiter et
croître plus d'une centaine de végétaux
légumes herbes aromatiques et fleurs
comestibles sur ces fameux carré de 40
cm tout en travaillant d'une manière
écologique respectueuse de la terre mon
principal allié en fait c'est la terre
d'abord mes légumes poussent et vont
puiser les éléments dont ils ont besoin
dans cette terre c'est un travail du
sol essentiellement à la base de compost
et de paillage de surface permanent on
voit jamais dans mon potager en carré un
sol à nu hein je je viens toujours avec
un paillage et d'ailleurs les allées en
herbé elles ne sont pas du tout là pour
faire jolie leur première fonction c'est
de d'être tondu et de basculer en
paillage pour régénérer le
sol on est là à l'école du du jardinage
en carré je suis là pour vous expliquer
cette manière de jardiner dans un
potager en carré à la française anne-mie
a le goût pour la transmission du savoir
ses premiers enseignements ont vu le
jour au Potager du Roi à Versailles
aujourd'hui son jardin lui sert de
support de formation et de
sensibilisation Estelle en formation
d'éducateur Environnement et
Développement Durable s'intéresse aux
aspects pédagogiques elle essaie de
minimiser au maximum son impact et rien
que ça je trouve que c'est c'est une
belle méthode parce que il y a de la
place pour tout le monde
pour la nature qui est déjà en place et
pour son jardin qu'elleamène en plus
c'est un site qui propose une dimension
environnementale très intéressante parce
qu'il y a le respect de la biodiversité
déjà et pour à partir de là c'est un
support intéressant pour travailler sur
des ateliers vers des un public
varié pour nourrir deux personnes il
faut huit grandes planches de culture ça
fait donc 8 x 9 carrés 72 légumes et en
jardinant et en faisant vraiment tourner
les cultures tout au long de l'année on
peut vivre en autonomie sans problème et
l'oxygénation du sol super encore chose
un jardin
pratique ludique esthétique c'est c'est
c'est très agréable c'est une méthode
qui m'a
séduite esthétique ergonomique
nécessitant un entretien réduit le
potager en carré n'est pas un mini
jardin mais bien un jardin nourricier
pour peu que l'on prenne soin du sol
sans production ou trancière
je peux pas demander beaucoup à la terre
si je lui en demandais beaucoup ça
supposerait que je rentrerai dans un
processus où il faudrait que j'utilise
par exemple des engrais donc non je lui
demande juste ce qu'elle peut m'apporter
et je crois que c'est ça la relation une
vraie relation de jardinier c'est de
savoir ce que ce sol est capable
d'apporter à mes légumes et de ne pas
lui en demander plus pour qu'il puisse
durer longtemps la méthode du jardin en
carré à la française simple efficace
pour participer à relancer un jardinage
utile et propre à embellir nos paysages
[Musique]
quotidiens